in this video i'm going to walk you
through the true competitive edge that
our companies have had in outperforming
other companies and if you don't know
who i am i'm a business investor i own
acquisition.com which is a portfolio of
companies that does about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you all
right so my name is alex mosey we
recently actually just sold a 66 percent
stake in two of our portfolio companies
for at a 46.2 million dollar valuation
so i don't sony any courses any
masterminds and coaching parts of any
mentorships i make these videos because
i had a lot of pain coming up in
learning these things and i hope that my
pain is not in vain and i like it
because it rhymes too what i want to
show you is probably one of the most
important questions that you have to
answer that will ultimately inform your
ability to compete within the
marketplace there are kind of two
schools of thought around business right
you've got the kind of brain brain side
there's my brain and then you've got
kind of the heart side of business and
the hard side is typically ignored
because this one is very quantifiable
and this one is not but the thing is is
that i would make the argument and leyla
and i would both make the argument that
this side even though it may sound
touchy-feely is actually the more
important side and i'll give you a
couple of examples before i give you
some tactics around this so when you've
seen like remember the titans or when
you see a new coach come into a football
team the actual strategy of the football
game hasn't fundamentally changed the
rules of the game are the same and
typically the strategy of the team
doesn't overarchingly change either they
just actually do it better and so the
doing it better and the higher output
from each person a lot of times is not
like 20 more a lot of times you can get
two times four times eight times more
out of the same people because they
believe in what they are doing and so
the thing is is that they makes that
might sound like one of these
motivational videos of like you have to
watch remember the titans together and
then everyone's kumbaya but there's
actually the real conversations that
have to occur in order to make the
business grow and so there's there's
lots of core questions that inform the
the
heart decisions of the company and so i
want to focus today on just one of them
right and so i'll give you an example of
some of them so it's like why do we
exist that is a very important question
that you have to answer and it has to be
answered well how do we behave what are
our values is an example of a question
that matters a lot who is in charge
right during what decisions who does
what those are all important questions
but the one i want to focus on is the
second one that i mentioned which is how
do we behave the reason that this is so
important is that it's one thing to know
where you're going but it's another
thing to know how you're going to get
there and so this is just as true in
business partnerships and marriage in
terms of what you want uh to have happen
and how you want to get there um as it
is in business okay and so what i want
to do is actually just walk you through
the three values that we have at
acquisition.com and why we believe them
and so from an overarching perspective
the way to come to values um is to look
at what are the non-negotiables okay and
so what i mean by that is and every
company is different because the core
thing about values is that they have to
be things that are true and innate to
you right like for example at southwest
uh have fun is one of their core values
and if someone does not want to have fun
or does not believe in the processes
that they do to have a good time then
that is a non-negotiable for them that
person cannot work at that company it is
a fireable offense and so these are not
aspirational these are not things that
you would like to have these are things
that are core to who you are as a person
and as a team all right and so when you
decide on these non-negotiables they are
by their very nature non-negotiable
which means that you hire based on these
you fire based on these and these are
the core spirit of the team and some of
the mistakes that i see when people make
values is that one they don't draw the
line in the sand and so one of the core
things about a value is that it has to
you have to be able to say this is not
this right you have to be able to say
okay between justice and mercy we lean
towards justice or we lean towards mercy
which means you have to repel people
with your values all right and so if
your values do not repel people then
they are not values they are platitudes
okay and so it's very important the next
thing is that when you're making your
values the values themselves need to be
ideally said in words that you would
normally say so if you have little
sayings inside of your community then
then a lot of times those can become
some of the values you have so for
example jim launch one of our first
portfolio companies uh speed is king do
the boring work these were different
ways i mean we could just say work ethic
but that's not the way we would have
said it we could have say be fast or
fast turnaround times but speed is king
was the way we would have said it okay
and so some of the things that i've
learned with this is also you cannot
have too many values as in
i'll say it differently you can't have
too many values you have to
be very selective at the true core
values of the company all right and so
if you're you know between two a lot of
times you just have to chunk up uh and
kind of get a broader value but they
become the core and i think that what we
have found is that three is the sweet
spot and that number has continued to
distill down over time but i think three
is the amount that your human brain can
comprehend as lenses to make a decision
right and the reason these values are so
important is that when you scale the
company you have to scale decision
making which means you have to scale the
frame with which you duplicate the
decision making process which is should
i hire this person even though alex is
not involved in this do they align with
the core values and the more stringent
the values the easier it is to have a
black and white example of i think this
person means two out of the three or one
out of three but we only accept three
out of three and i will tell you this as
an additional point if you have core
values in the business i would relay
them to all aspects of your life if you
would not do business with someone for a
decade do not do business with them for
a day it's one of the novalisms that i
like a lot and so if you wouldn't if you
don't want to deal with this client for
a decade don't deal with them for a day
if you wouldn't deal with this employee
for a decade don't deal with them for a
day you have to and and the extent to
which you hold your line of intolerance
around these truly non-negotiables will
dictate the health of the organization
and if you make these non-negotiables
and realize that there are people in
your organization in your client base
that do not ascribe to these then you
must make the changes to fix it and that
is the pruning of the tree that will
ultimately grow the tree all right these
are the short-term pains for the
long-term gains all right so what i want
to do for the rest of this video is walk
you through the three that we have that
we look for in the entrepreneurs of the
companies uh that own the portfolio
companies that we invest in uh that we
look for internally in terms of the
employees that we hire and grow onto our
team so this is both internal and
external for us and then finally what we
hold ourselves to all right and so these
are the three for acquisition.com
number one
is unimpeachable character and as we
were coming up with these over time we
had like loyalty was something that was
really important to us like absolute
integrity was something that was really
important to us like long-term minded
was something that was really important
to us and we were like we had all these
words on the board and whatnot it was
like what's the what's the what's the
through line on this what's the thread
that kind of weaves all these things
together and for us it was we just want
to deal with people who have
unimpeachable character if someone has a
wisp or an edge that just feels a little
bit off these are things that earlier in
my career i would i would rationalize
and be like but they have all these
other things and the the more seasoned
i've gotten this the more i just don't
negotiate on it it's like if i don't
feel like this person is unimpeachable
character i won't do business with them
it's because if i wouldn't do it and a
great frame of this is like would i do
this with this person for a decade no
then i don't want to do business with
them for a day and so here's three
frames that you can look at that i like
a lot right and this is uh this is a
little story that i got from a friend of
mine who was talking to somebody who's
on seal team six and they were
explaining the difference between people
who were seals versus people who were on
steel team six right he said listen at
this level every single naval sea navy
seal would lay down their life for
another guy he's like that's kind of the
ticket of entry to just be a seal right
he's like but the people who are team
six he's like we have other things that
we have to look at right you know if
someone has an ego they're going to
become he's like the hard problem is
somebody who's who has an ego but is a
really high performer because they
become cancers on the team right and a
lot of us have these people or have had
these people in our companies and i can
tell you they are such a cancer like you
don't know the damage they are doing to
your culture which is ultimately
affecting the overall company
performance all right but the first the
first through line here for us and the
easiest one is like if we see someone
who has an ego then then then we already
know that they're not going to be
they're not going to be receptive to
feedback they're going to point fingers
they're going to always think that their
idea is best uh and they're going to
think they're better and ultimately we
just don't want to do it that type of
person right but here's two two
questions that they asked uh in team sex
that i really liked a lot he says not
only can i trust this person with my
life he said can i trust this person
with my wife can i go and leave and
leave my wife with this guy for a month
and expect nothing to happen can i
expect no passing comments can i expect
no no moves no flirts no no no
stray looks because they have
unimpeachable character the the second
one was can i trust this person with my
money if i were to give this person way
more money than they have ever had and
say i'm gonna leave i need you to hold
on to this i don't know when i'm gonna
be back but i will be back for it can i
wait
a month can i wait a year can i wait a
decade and expect for that money to be
sitting in the same corner that i left
it and these are just questions that i
ask when i'm looking at someone and
thinking like does this person have
unimpeachable character under what
conditions do i think i could put what
hot water could i put this tea bag in
and see what's on the inside come out
when you're asking questions and and for
us when we're asking questions on
interviews for uh candidates for the
company but also when we're asking
questions to the entrepreneurs what
we're looking for is not even their
answer but how they answer them to give
us insight into their character and so
for us unimpeachable character is the
absolute foundation upon which
everything we have is built the second
one is sincere candor and the reason
that this is so important is that we
believe that you cannot make progress
without feedback and if you can't give
feedback then you cannot identify the
deficits that exist in order to improve
them and so for us having sincere candor
is two aspects one of them is having the
self-awareness to accurately identify
situation and deliver the feedback that
is good but also to be on the other side
of this and have the humility to receive
feedback not take it personally and to
improve as a result right and so we look
at this on the portfolio company side
the entrepreneurs that we invest in and
then also on the team side of the
candidates that we choose to bring in do
we think that this person can take
feedback do we think this person has the
intellectual wherewithal the emotional
awareness to to give feedback in a way
that is that is useful and constructive
those are the types of things that
really matter in an organization because
when you have these unspoken things and
these these these these wounds or these
resentments what happens is the space
starts to fill up between people and
then their communication becomes less
effective and fundamentally like running
a company is based on how well you can
communicate it's clarity of
communication and so that is why this is
so important for us as an investment
company and also um in terms of the
companies that we look look into to help
grow and so the third piece here is
competitive greatness and i think and we
borrowed this from john wooden because
layla and i are both huge fans of his
which is are you at your best when your
best is needed the enjoyment of a hard
challenge that is how he defines it but
if you're thinking about this and this
is how the value should stack up when
you're looking at your own values which
is how do we behave with this account
within your company the three values
should give you a vibe for the company
overall like if you read these three
things you should think to yourself okay
people with unimaginable character who
have sincere candor and competitive
greatness this should give you a vibe of
the type of place that this might be if
i were to list off do the boring work
speed is king have humility now there
might be some similarities there between
these ones and and uh and our gym launch
one though don't sugarcoat it right
which is kind of a different version of
sincere candy a different flavor same
concept right is that you should be able
to read those values and say like i
think i get the vibe for this place and
you should also be able to say i don't
think this person will fit in and so
imagine you're interviewing someone and
you're like okay i think this person can
both give and receive feedback okay and
they can do that effectively you know
like i think they're very solid people i
think they have an impeachable character
when i think about the different um
different things and stressors i would
expose them to i think that they would
hold strong but it's like oh i don't
know if they're like really driving i
don't know if they're ambitious i don't
know if they really want to like take
the hill and do big [ __ ] right well then
but they have two out of the three i
think they could still maybe fit for the
world's like no if these are
non-negotiables then they are
non-negotiables and you have to continue
to massage these until you get exactly
the true core that gives you that
triangle the three lenses to look
through if you have 10 values it's
impossible to make a decision it's it's
it's also almost impossible to think
through candidates there's too many
lenses and so that is why we found three
to be the sweet spot for us and so and
look at a different one let's say you've
got somebody who's competitively great
super ambitious super hard charging
right can accept and give feedback but
you don't think they're characters there
like you think if if things got hard
they would revert to something different
then that's somebody that you don't want
on the team because things are going to
be hard in the future that's a virtual
guarantee that within business things
will get hard and so you're just
predicting what's going to happen in the
future and just avoiding the landmine
and so what i've also learned is a
tangible side note is that a lot of
times success in business is just making
fewer mistakes it's trying to avoid the
dumb decisions trying to avoid the
people that are going to become cancers
in your company more than it's making
very smart moves a lot of times uh the
level of activity continues to decrease
as we've weathered and scaled our our
portfolio but i think the the skill with
which we execute the things has improved
because we were just more deliberate and
we try we still make plenty of mistakes
but we try to make fewer of the dumb
ones over time this video is for making
the values within your business what are
the things that you stand for what are
the non-negotiables with the company
what are the things that you want all of
your clients to adhere to what are the
things that you want all of your team to
adhere to and what are the lenses that
we can use to truly draw a line in the
sand and say this person does not fit in
and if most people don't fit to the
non-negotiables that you have
good
most people shouldn't be in your company
all right so lots of love mosey nation
if you're new welcome i make these
videos because i went through a lot of
pain and suffering to try and figure
this stuff out and i hope that that pain
is out of vain lots of people are broke
don't want you to be one of them enjoy
the next video bye